density column by Hari her on Jo Kumar
defining the problem i am trying to mix
a bunch of liquids and when I do I want
it to stack on top of each other because
of the liquids different densities
generating concepts I try many
combinations to find out what order I
need to put in the liquids on the final
project I tried over 20 combinations and
then my mom recorded the results for me
here are some of our ideas after many
trials I figured out the best solution
and I tried it many times our smaller
scale before I went on to the full-size
later I decided to go to full size and
so I did and this is how I got there and
what the final result looked like
you
a value very solution I think it turned
out very good and that it looks great I
was scared it might get messed up but
fortunately he had outstanding results
my mom said I'd look cool beautiful my
dad said that looked very cool so
overall I think it was it was success
you